hey guys Ryan Wright is here and so is
brandy price so today we're gonna watch
a video for Brandy's favorite actor of
all time John Travolta called the forger
it's a crime thriller okay I like
grandpa is John Travolta still taken
seriously I haven't seen him in anything
in a very long time last couple things I
saw man were really just poorly received
that one hunting movie with De Niro oh I
didn't see that and then he did like
some stupid comedy Alex indels no John
Travolta would be good for the
expendables Oh Christopher plumbers in
it and as you know Brandi he recently
won an Oscar it's probably gonna be an
okay movie I'm Patrick Bateman language
and some violence okay you told me the
truth how did you get out nine months to
go and what he called Keegan beginning
of June
yeah do it we make fortune why sitting
steering that's impossible see the yes
you go back to prison Oklahoma so his
master now where is he upstairs
then how'd you get out for years living
here we're doing fine then you come let
up he'll turn out approve and all the
time my son ty something you don't got
yeah I told you I break his neck I can't
hear myself so far your boy has violated
his whole life can I drop you off
somewhere copy I got thanks to go the
same problem because it's not true
Hollywood is a lion Air fate I need you
don't pop I want to push the door unit
house musics thinking about surprised a
little bit an idea what you're doing may
we always have enough bubble that
treatment now
my business owner
the stupid plan on purchasing the Pluto
it's so thrown off when the vibe just
totally change it was a super serious
drama dealing with crime and then it
just suddenly became this fun criminal
heist movie oh dude what the book just
happened last half of that trailer I
couldn't started off that way in a women
fine exactly it's two very different
heavy emotions like suddenly switch to
oh you know what I thought was weird
John Travolta's face looks I know looks
like he's had to go back to get a Botox
injections several times or not even
it's not even just the Botox not that
his face is completely immovable it's
like it looks just different whereas
like Christopher Plummer looks normal
yeah because he never got plastic
surgery yeah that's more than plastic
surgery I think yeah he's got horrible
plastic surgery you could see it in his
lips and his cheeks yeah look so what's
on I feel so bad thing that we didn't
get plastic surgery then I am sorry
there's something about like aging
gracefully which is great yeah it's
beautiful when someone can do it yeah
Veronica's gonna age gracefully mm-hmm
just gonna be hot as [ __ ] when she's in
her forties and fifties man that's
probably true that was that I'm serious
John Travolta is okay no I can't accept
I just don't know what what I can how
can you judge what this movie's gonna be
like because it's such a serious [ __ ]
trailer at first where it's like he has
to go back into the crime world and it's
like oh no that's that's not what he
should do but he has to but then it
turns into I guess for having a fun time
now as he goes along the ground like I
thought it was really weird how the dad
like don't know you said you were never
we're doing fine without you and then
all of a sudden they're helping him yeah
I thought it could have been like a cool
kind of drama where a guys trying to
like break away from the criminal life
you know instead of I guess you should
do this because this is how him and his
song son or bonding right now right this
movie looks like it's gonna have a great
message about hundreds things can be
horribly wrong but if you could make
crimes together you'll bond yeah anyway
guys thanks for telling me that trailer
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the bird real rejects
were escorted show neck and Brandi has a
channel to it's a damn go chant one
course [ __ ] in Japan movie reviews own
way [ __ ] [ __ ] that's right
that's what I was wack whenever I hear a
Boston accent salton first thing that
comes to mind yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah like wow you curse yeah I just
think of the departed oh yeah that's
another thing there was a time where to
be a coup crying character or crime at
all it was New York that was the go-to
place now it is Boston everything is it
boss I think it was the department cuz
the departed like just a huge film then
in won best picture and it was like a
defined I'm like yeah and then the town
perpetuated yeah it's cuz like you were
getting actors who were originally from
Boston doing things like that that's
what i was thinking him i was like this
could be something like the talent you
know it's like this is the last one
because the town was cool and a lot of
its own ways okay it was it was cool it
was a cool [ __ ] film i loved it i
don't know what they're doing with this
movie I think that's where Casey Affleck
started being taken seriously yeah oh
and there was gone baby gone and then
there was edge of darkness with mel
gibson everyone saw that one and then
with the one with the two brothers the
fighter no no not the fun there's the
fire there is a fighter that's not that
when i was thinking of out of the
furnace out of the furnace Christian
Bale Woody Harrelson BAM called it